From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, okay. Good afternoon. Today is August 15, 2013. Speaking is David Klein from the History Department at Virginia Tech.
Also working with the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill.
We are conducting an interview today for the Civil Rights History Project of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Behind the camera is John Bishop of Media Generation and we have the honor today of interviewing John and Jean Rosenberg.
Jean is on Channel 1 and John is on Channel 2 and I just want to thank you both very much for being part of this project.
Glad to be here.
And we'll start today with we're going to start with Jean and I just wanted to...
I usually start with people's family backgrounds in the belief that maybe you'll prove me wrong but that often the way that people are raised and the ideals and the influence,
you can see later what a person ends up doing and so I'm curious, I'm always curious about the family life of people as they are raised.
So if you could tell us a little bit about your backgrounds and whether you see any of those kind of...
Oh, absolutely. I mean I think that's absolutely true in my observation of life too.
So I was born in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania and adopted by a transplanted New York couple and my father having been uprooted from his Presbyterian community was looking for a place to a spiritual growth and connected with the Quakers.
And subsequently we... he joined and I joined and then later my brother and my mother joined the Quaker meeting in Abington, Pennsylvania.
And that led to intense exposure to social action and commitment to the idea that there's that of God in every person.
And that and also to the fact that people can arrive at decision making by consensus.
And I think that that's a very important element in my later years that was a very good background for me to be living here in Appalachia.
So I went from there, I went...
Were there particular projects or focus, social justice focus in that meeting or...?
Oh well of that meeting obviously that meeting and the Philadelphia yearly meeting were always involved in racial issues.
And definitely in war concern about peace, the peace process and how to accomplish that.
So I was always involved in those... that young friends movement as growing up and it guided me to apply to Earlham College in Richmond, Indiana, which is a Quaker school.
And then I graduated there in June 1965.
And you were born in 1943?
Well you worked in... you went to a summer work camp in Mexico.
Right, sure. But yeah.
That sort of thing and your mom was on the picket line for peace, right?
Right.
That's what...
Witness for peace, good old women.
So let's hear a little bit.
I mean just a part and parcel of my growing up years.
And I in my high school at Abington High School, which is a suburban Philadelphia High School, refused to take part in ARA drills,
as I felt that it was a psychology of fear and terror and that in fact in a truth hiding under your desk was not going to help you in a cold war situation.
And therefore I refused. And so I was taken to the principal's office and called a Communist Dup.
And then I was directed that when we had the drill I was to sit in front of the plate glass window so I'd be the first to be killed.
So you know, when people do that, when they take those kinds of positions, then you are...
You know, you're even more committed to thinking about what it is you're doing and why.
And so I was able to arrange for a film called Operation Correction to go along.
This is going on and on.
But you know, I mean I arranged for that to be shown in my high school just so that people could see that there was another side to a story.
And I felt that was very important.
This is the second day in a row that Operation Correction has been mentioned.
Really?
Yeah. Where was he? He was a minister that showed her that his community got run out of town for a short while.
Well, you know, luckily I was an honor student.
So, you know, I think I got more leeway because I was able to do well on tests.
So, and you started college in 1961?
At Wilmington College. I did not go to Irland, initially.
I went and I waited too long to apply and so I had the offer of waiting out a year and coming with an ex-class or...
And I went to Wilmington College which is in Wilmington, Ohio, which is another Quaker School.
And then I transferred in my junior year.
So, and having been raised in the family and in the community that you've been telling us about, with a lot of awareness of issues, social issues and justice issues,
how were you of other things that were happening in the country?
I was part of the civil rights movement, but were you aware of earlier traditions and what was going on?
You know, were there particular movements for you?
Well, I mean, I was very aware of the Vietnam War and the lead up to that.
And I was one of the protesters at my at Irland, you know, that would go regularly to stand and witness against the war.
And it was, however, my friend Dorothy, we referred to as Landsberg. She was Dorothy Shelton Landsberg Landsberg, then.
I met her at Irland College and she was involved with...
Her father was an internal revenue lawyer in Washington, D.C.
And he helped get her a summer internship with John Doar in the summer of 64, where she worked very hard on the developing an index of...
from the FBI reports on clan members, which was then subsequently helpful when jury selection took place in a number of cases.
And, well, I mean, we were all... she was part of the student at, you know, political activities committee and so was I.
And then I met John Doar. That's when I met John Doar.
She invited him to speak at a convocation at Irland. And she didn't want to introduce him because she was afraid he would tease her in front of everyone.
So she got her buddy Jean to introduce him. And while we were eating together, he said, well, have you ever thought about joining me establishment?
And I said, no. And he said, why don't you do that? And why don't you give it a try?
And so since I wasn't focused on where I would be after I graduated, we had thought about going to law school, but that wasn't really a passion.
So I did, in fact, apply and was accepted as a research analyst for the Civil Rights Division, the Department of Justice in June of 65.
And I then went on to qualify my loyalty oath and I still had the job.
And what did you say?
I've inserted in the loyalty oath that I would, in so far as my conscience would allow, I would, you know, support and defend the United States.
So they kept me anyway. And that was when I started working as a research analyst.
And went from, we worked on all kinds of cases. We worked on school desegregation cases, police brutality cases, employment cases, during the time that I was there. I left in the spring of 1970.
Okay. So let's switch over to John and then we'll bring him up to that same moment.
So John, if you could introduce yourself and a little bit about your background as well, it would be wonderful.
Well, I'm John Rosenberg. I'm Jean's husband of 46 years. She's put up with me over that period, hopefully for another maybe not 46, but a few more.
I was born in Germany October 7, 1931, a long time ago.
My father was a teacher in the Jewish school system. I say the Jewish school system. He actually, when Adolf Adolf Hitler set up a secret required the schools to be segregated so that Jewish kids were separated out.
He and another man set up the school for Jewish kids and the city was named Magdeburg, Germany.
The city then, about 300,000 people, a large industrial center, which was bombed pretty heavily during the war.
And I grew up there and then as a young child, the first day of school is a big deal.
And if I remember, you go to school, start around Easter and they give you a big conical bag with all kinds of gifts in it.
I say that because we have, there's a family picture of me holding this conical bag with our gifts on the first day of school.
But I was actually, by that point, my father's class. He was a teacher and then I also worked for the Jewish welfare agency.
He was teaching courses to people who were interested in going to Israel. He wanted to go to Israel, but my mother said, no, we are, if we leave the country, we're going to go to the United States because her mother and father and two sisters had immigrated to the country and she wasn't really interested in going to Israel.
Although he had had one sister and a brother go to Israel at an early time as into a small cooperative community.
In any event, we lived in a building next to a synagogue. We had an apartment there because dad worked for that welfare agency and he also assisted the rabbi and the local congregation.
We were there during Kristallnacht and they bombed the synagogue. They didn't, they were somewhat careful about the synagogue because there was a hospital next door. Otherwise, as you probably know, all the other synagogues, primarily were burned down or the ones most synagogues in Germany were burned.
The way my dad was in a concentration camp for 11 days and we were fortunate enough to get out of the country. We came, we spent a year in Holland. My father started a school in this detention camp and we had no materials but he taught by the Socratic Method teaching us verbally.
We came to this country on February 22, 1940 on pretty much the last ship. His brother and mother were on board. I'm not sure about his mother. I think both of another ship of several weeks lighter in the ship was required. It was turned around because the war started.
They didn't get out. His brother was killed. He lost the, there was another family. One of his sisters had married. The fellow was on a stock exchange who was, they were fairly well off. They had five kids in Rotterdam and that family was gone and family in Germany.
Most of his, so he lost his substantial and his mother was also killed during that period. She lived right very close to the end of the war. In fact, his brother were married during the, while he was in the concentration camp and we met his widow in Israel several years later.
But so we came and then we, my father when we came to this country, it was very difficult to find a job. There were so many immigrants in New York. And so he learned of community in Spartanburg, SC, South Carolina and Gastonian North Carolina. They had substantial Jewish communities but no rabbi.
And so he, that's what drew him there. I mean, we always, I'm not sure which comes first. But during the week he swept floors in a textile mill and on weekends he alternated going to these two communities. And I always thought it was pretty amazing because he was writing sermons when he could hardly just still learning to speak English.
But after three years we then moved. He learned of a better position in a textile mill in Gastonia, NC or in Lowell North Carolina.
Fellow who came from our hometown who in Magdeburg, a parent who had it mill they are brought a bunch of equipment and started textile mill.
And the idea learned went to work as an office manager if I remember right. But he basically learned the textile business and stayed as a white collar worker and was very active in the local synagogue and I grew up in town of Gastonia, NC for practical purposes. We'd been in Spartanburg, SC for three years.
So I grew up in Gastonia, NC and you know worked after school and scouting was a big part of my life. I was an eagle scout and spent summers as a counselor and went off to Duke University as a freshman.
May I ask what the racial dynamics were in Gastonia, NC at that time?
I would first tell about the fact that being a German immigrant they took away the binoculars. I just think that's an interesting caveat.
After the war started when we were aliens, my parents weren't citizens and Gene always said the FBI or Treasury agents came to our apartment one day knocked on the door and they required they took the binoculars that my parents had and the shortwave, the radio that had a capability of getting shortwave.
But they were quite embarrassed to see that we had Franklin Delano Roosevelt's picture on the wall and you have this fairly patriotic thankful family to be in this country and they came and took this equipment away from us.
It was I think mutually embarrassed very. They eventually brought it back after the war. We got this stuff back.
But we were Gastonia, NC was a segregated society. We had black schools. We had you were living in a segregated society.
You always think back on those days the Jewish community, most of the members of that community as was true and many southern communities were pretty well off.
They had their parents and grandparents had come to these communities or come to the area of his petalers and started selling merchandise and then eventually built a retail store.
The community was well off. I'm not sure that anybody had ever seen a portrait of what we were relatively poor Jewish working family until we got there.
It was a nice community and several other people were. I think they respected my father a lot because he had such a huge knowledge of Jewish culture and could read Hebrew.
We could quote the next verse in the Torah for five books of Moses if you started him anywhere in there which was not that unusual for someone who had all that biblical background or studied in the some he had been to the seminary.
He actually came from family with nine children in northwest Germany and one of his early teaching assignments was in my mother's hometown.
She was a young 16 year old and they got to know each other and by when she was 18 they got married.
He was working in the mill and I had some of jobs in the mill and it was as you lived as you know, every Jewish community was thankful to be there economically.
They couldn't get into the country club for many despite their wealth. Most of them were not at that point. The country clubs were segregated.
But they certainly took no major initiatives in trying to help integrate the community or call attention to the fact that this is wrong.
I think you basically grew up with it and when you move into that system looking back, I'm sure my parents were so grateful to be there that they were. That was the last thing they had in mind.
Although my parents, my mother especially, I mean my summer job, I worked off when you're in the mill you interact with lots of black folks.
But everybody kind of knows where the lines are.
I don't know if there was any Gastonia, NC's history is sort of interesting. There are book called preachers and mill hands. They had riots in the 20s and 30s around the textile worker issue and working conditions.
But it wasn't racial. It wasn't that was not a racial issue.
So the schools were totally segregated and that's just the way life was. My mother had my mom was known to be a very friendly person. She was and didn't start work.
She decided after the kids were all gone that she wanted to be a saleswoman to do work in the local department store which she did.
But she had people coming by where they were black or white and she would interact with them and offer them bite the eat or whatever.
And I think the family in that sense, I didn't have don't recall. I don't think I had any friends in the black community.
A few years ago, not too many years ago, 10 years ago I think Gastonia, NC, the class president of the year before me or two years, promoted a joint anniversary of the classes from 1948 so that the black and white graduates would now be adults would be together.
I think it was a one time thing. But I remember that Gaston County Gaston County is actually one of the voting rights cases. I went to the Supreme Court. I think they challenged the mechanism under which Gaston County was selected.
But from that I was a Duke in a, I went to undergraduate school at Duke. It wasn't, it was sort of between Duke and the University of North Carolina.
And there was a trustee at the time named C Park who was from Gastonia, NC. And he encouraged me to go to Duke because he thought he could secure and he did secure a tuition scholarship for me for the first four, what we hope would be four years.
Unfortunately, he died after the first year. And I was then interviewed and said, you're making too much money working in the dining room where you got chips for food or whatever. And they said, you got to have to pay your own tuition.
Which I did and stayed in, but it was always sort of gosh. I was pretty poor. My dad was sending me 25 bucks a month or something and they took away the tuition scholarship.
But I did get, I was a chem major Duke and I in ROTC. And so I ended, we went into the United States Air Force. And I spent three years in England as an navigator.
London, very close to a lot of my colleagues had a very interesting year fly. We went, at that time it was a period of the Cold War.
So many of our exercises were on the close to the Russian border. We dropped the special forces and a very military period.
Totally contrary to what I was picketing the Pentagon. Right. Well, she was picketing the Pentagon. So after I came out of the service, I worked for a year for a chemical firm, Rohm and Haas, Philadelphia.
And I was just asking about the air force. The air force was integrated at that point. What was your experience there in terms of?
Well, I think it was integrated. And it was sort of in one of the things I relate as there was pretty much a life changing experience for me.
Because we were very close to each other, black sand whites. And we, on one of those occasions, we brought a plane back to this country.
And the radar operator was a fellow from Charleston, South Carolina named Abe Jenkins. And when we brought the plane back to Long Island, we went by way of Iceland and then Greenland.
It was a little, it was an SA-16 SA-16 SA-16 called a SA-16 SA-16, which flies at about 160 miles an hour. So if you've got a very heavy headwind, you might be moving along at 20 or 30 miles an hour over the ground, which on at least one occasion we did.
Because of the island, we were just about to run out of fuel anyway. We got back when we got to Long Island, even I had a week to go home. And we got on the train together in New York.
And we got to Washington. We were in uniform. And when we got to Washington, Abe said he would see me later. And I said, where are you going? He said, I'm going to the back of the train where the blacks are.
And I said, and he did. And I thought, this is bad. This is really wrong. And maybe I'm sure in the back of my mind, maybe somewhere along the way, I'll have a chance to do something about that, which show.
So you're right. It was a, I mean, in the sense that I ended up going to silver. I'm sure that particular incident had a lot to do with the way, I mean, it sorry, hit me in the head.
I don't know whether it was the first trip back when we were together. I went to an navigation school with many black members and it never seemed to be.
I'm going to cut just for a minute. Yeah. That mosquito. That mosquito is coming from me.
I'm going to take little breaks. It was interesting because in navigation school, my four of us lived together off base, four students and two of them from Texas and one was from New Orleans.
And it was at a time when people were we, I think, I don't think I had, I didn't have a car, but I know that one of them did and we had this Confederate Air Force sticker on there.
And it was still the institution was as an institution, but there was still a fair amount of racism and joking and that sort of thing.
And going on and it was all part of the way you lived, but you also, I think, I think they saw that the members, the black officers who were in navigation training at that time, you know, it was their first, everybody's first experience in a major way of living together, working together and eventually having to depend on each other.
So that was just leading up to the time that we were when I went to England. And then we were, you have crew members and you're in some fairly dangerous situations and you just know for sure that the color of your skin didn't make any difference at all.
You're involved in a very difficult exercise in which they're depending on you or you're depending on them as much as you are any other anybody else.
And for you personally, I don't know whether if there are African Americans in your classes at Duke or was this really for you the first time to be in Coast Park Simulator?
It was. Duke was still a white school. Duke was still segregated. I had a Jewish quota.
Yeah, they had a quota for Jewish, which I don't think I was aware of in the sense that, you know, we thought, well, this is the number.
But when I went to Duke, the two roommates I had were both Jewish. We weren't put there by accident. But there was a Jewish fraternity.
Did you come into each other about that? I don't know. You know, it turned out that one of them and I were lifelong friends.
The other one of them became a doctor. Norman Rosenbaum went to the University of Virginia and ended up in New England.
And he was always, Norman was much more of a loner. He played, he was from Norfolk and had played basketball. But he always went off to study on his own.
And then Marty and I ultimately joined the Jewish fraternity, which was a big, new experience for me.
I've never been with a lot of Jews. I was president of my senior class in high school. And just one of the boys, as it were, you know, you felt you were a member of, I don't know, that the Jewishness, I never felt any real, religious discrimination.
I mean, we were always, as Gene said, she was a very good student. People, I had a younger brother who did, who was also doing well in school.
And I was involved in a lot of activities and always working after school. And, you know, so there was people I think did respect the family.
And as I say, I was president of my sophomore class and then I gave my senior class. So I lost my career thought.
I wanted to say about my history is interestingly enough when I went to Wilmington College, which is a Quaker School, they intentionally assigned me a black roommate
because they didn't know how the other gals on my hall would respond to being integrated in 61.
So I got the black roommate from the Bronx and we've been lifelong friends. But it's interesting, you know, I mean, because I was a Quaker.
You know, it wasn't, you know, just because you go to a Quaker School there few and far between usually.
And she has been well. And so the three of us, Marty, this other third, the two roommates, Marty, Sak and I, he recently passed away. He was a lawyer in Jacksonville.
And he was, and we became very, very close. As I say, we both joined the fraternity and the third roommate didn't.
He was, instead independent on pretty much on his own and so Marty and I, but you had this Jewish fraternity on campus at Duke, which at that time was only Jewish.
And after my second year, I was a delegate to a national convention in which the charter was changed to allow non-Jewish members, although it's still primarily a Jewish fraternity, I think.
But it did expose me to a whole new system. I mean, I, this, it was very helpful to, it was nice. These were pretty close.
There were very few Jewish women on the, these campus, but they were also integrated. So there was a conscious effort by the administration at that time to keep the number of students down.
Of course, today it's, there's, there's multi-national, multi-cultural, multi-religious, a very, very fine institution.
But I then went to the, after I worked for the chemical company for a year, I was thinking I wanted to do something that might be a little more useful and maybe use my brain a little bit and decide to go to the, to law school.
And then whether I really figured out already that I was going to be on the civil rights division, I'm not sure.
I, I, Jewish had a fairly small, he was a very Jewish chambers who then was number one in our became number one in our class had a fairly small circle of non of white friends socially or to the extent that he was going to spend any time.
And he spent any time not studying. So we did become friendly during those, those years at Chapel Hill and kind of kept up with each other over the years.
I was kept up sort of with his great, his great career. And he would, we would exchange letters. And once we'll always see each other at, you know, at conferences and he'd send a little money to Appalred when I was over here.
So from the, so after I finished law school, I was pretty determined to be in the civil rights division. And that's, I actually spent the first month and a half in the Antitrust Division waiting to get an interview with John Doar, who at that time was going down to the University of Mississippi every week too, because it was the time of getting James Meredith into Ole Miss.
And so after I interviewed with John, there were only eight or nine lawyers at that time in the division. Then I was delighted to start.
So why civil rights? And you said early on in your locker room, you saw an interest there. What was it?
Well, I mean, I think it was a combination of having been born in Germany and seeing and thinking about the hall of this Holocaust history of ours and the terrible genocide that went subject to the history of the history of the whole world.
And then seeing that the Jewish people were, throughout Europe were subjected to. And then seeing really in having been in the service with people who were black and thinking that this is a caste system is wrong in this country, being very proud of this country.
And I'm still, I think it's the greatest place to find this country in the world. And there's just some things that we need to keep working on to make it better.
And I feel I felt that this was a place I could make a contribution.
I thought that maybe as a southerner to some extent communication wise, it's a little easier.
I don't know that I'd hoped to change any of how many people I've changed whose mind I would change. But it just seemed that the division, which was representing the United States in these cases, and that we would, that you have the force of the country behind you and that it was going to be difficult work and challenging work that was just kind of getting underway.
The division was created just 1957. And the, really didn't have very much authority to do very much itself. And the lawyers who had been working sort of as civil rights division lawyers have been sitting at their desks in Washington and were kind of reviewing papers and didn't do it very much until John Doerr came in 1960 with six months to go and Eisenhower administration and realize what you've got to do is go to the south and talk to the people who are having the problems.
And try to do something. And that was he being a trial lawyer. He said you got to go find out what the facts are. And so he was working on those, he was quite a heroic. I thought for him to take this job was six months to go. He got a call and from the eye, nobody else was willing to do it.
And so he was actually working on one of these cases in Louisiana where a cotton farmer had registered to vote and the cotton ginners then conspired to refuse to gin as cotton because he's got name was Charles Atlas the same as the body builder.
And so the story goes if Robert F. Kennedy would become attorney general was reviewing the pleading in the affidavits in those cases and saw and had talked with John and realized that this was really a very special person who could get some things done.
I think there is a little more to it. He actually had a conversation about where things were and John explained to him by that time during after he was sort of in charge during the transition from one administration to the next.
And so Robert F. Kennedy asked John to stay on and then he did and eventually became also assistant attorney general but he was in charge of the trial work and he taught us basically his system of trying cases.
So anyway, we can talk if you want to go back to Gene or how would you want to go back and forth. I just want to follow up on that. How closely did the attorney general and the division work?
Oh, very much so. I mean, I think the attorney general Robert F. Kennedy at that point was the boss and he he but he clearly wanted us to when I think the mission of the division and at that time in 1962 was really from a legal standpoint to challenge the voting system of voting discrimination against blacks throughout the South.
Now, other things happened and that was like James Meredith couldn't anticipate the timing of when he was going to go to Ole Miss in 1962.
And so protecting him became an issue that took considerable division time. Lawyers were spending the or my I don't know, I gave his name Civil Rights Division attorneys cohort who is another lawyer who's in Washington who actually tried one of the big.
Colmining cases here a few years ago and wrote a book called the Buffalo Creek disaster. Gerald while I was waiting to see John, John would initially spend all his time with Meredith.
I have a really nice picture in him and I can get a McChain Marshall McChain and John with James Meredith being confronted by Lt. Gov. Paul B. Johnson Jr when they weren't going to admit him.
We might want to put in here. No, it's not when here it's up on my wall and the other room. I have to bring it down.
But after reconstruction, blacks were basically prohibited from voting. I mean they wiped the rolls clean in most of these counties. In these rural counties, Mississippi and Alabama, I was assigned.
Initially I spent a short amount of time in Georgia. There had been a series of church burnings and I mean this efforts to protest, the failure to let people register to vote were going on all over in these various states.
We were assigned geographically and the first few months I was in Georgia working with a lawyer named Gerald "Jerry" Heilbron who had practiced in Fort Smith Arkansas for many years was one of the few private attorneys who actually, few lawyers who were private attorneys but who, when the racial issues started coming up, was viewed as a liberal and then basically lost all his business and Burke Marshall heard about it.
They connected and he came up and spent some time eventually went to the community relations service. Jerry was sort of a glad handler but a very liberal and is thinking and wanted to do something about racial discrimination.
So I worked with Jerry for a little while and then we actually one of our very first cases with not a very good outcome. Deputy Sheriff in Sassar, Georgia, which is near America and that very difficult area, you know the area.
There were three or four black students who had gone from door to door to register people to vote and he chased them out of town with a pistol.
And so we filed a criminal information and we had a trial in federal court and we need to move stuff. Anyway, the jury wasn't out very long but it was my first case to put on some witnesses and...
How difficult was to get with it?
And I'm...
Van Hoffman.
Van Hoffman, post.
Yes, I remember.
I was always dodging him.
Okay.
No, I'm not going to tell you that.
Well, okay.
So...
Oh, you were asking, we were talking about the...
This was my first experience in a federal criminal prosecution with the Deputy Sheriff. The jury wasn't out terribly long.
That's right. I was just about to ask how difficult it was to find people willing to testify.
In this case, the major witnesses were these black students who had been affected.
And interesting sidelight, although I always thought a lot of Gerald "Jerry" Heilbron was that he had... he was late getting there. I think a plane was late.
So the judge wanted to start the case. So I actually examined the witnesses.
And the early witnesses, before we got to the cross-examination of the deputy, which was after the jury was going to do it.
But I was calling these black students by their last names, Mr. Mrs. Mrs. Mrs.
So I could see from looking around, this was people who thought that was pretty unusual.
And I'm not sure that even Jerry agreed with it a little later. I don't recall later whether he in his summation referred to them by their first names.
He was still of the view, I think, that we could persuade southerners to comply, because even coming from his community in Fort Smith, I think he felt bad about leaving it, you know, you kind of...
That so he was still trying to sort of... well, if we're going to be a little more southerner about the way we... if we're more... if they'll understand us, maybe we can make things happen in a consensual way, as the Quakers would say.
I think the clan wasn't about to do that, and many others weren't about to do it.
But then I was transferred over to Mississippi towards the end of 1962 in the beginning of 1963.
But the answer to your question is, I think... well, it was in that case, the three black students were willing to testify.
I think it was always took a lot of courage.
Were they local? Were they coming up?
They were local. These three students that had been chased away, I think, were from another community, because he chased them out of town.
I can't remember the details of it, but they were... I think all three of them were black, and I think they'd been recruited by SNCC or one of the groups from Albany.
They may have been part of the Albany. There was a large movement in Albany, and I went to Albany several times during...
I'm just vague on that memory, because I spent a little time there, but CB King was administered...
I had spoken... had gone to and met with several times, and trying to...
What we were trying to do was be prepared and to get information back to the Attorney General's office or the Civil Rights Division about what was happening in these communities.
We didn't have any success. Really, I'm in the Georgia Church burnings. I think those were among the first things that were events, and they were at night.
Those witnesses that you would have had to have some way into the white community or into the clan or whoever did those shootings and burnings.
We got better at it, I think, as time went on. The FBI got better with it as time went on after the Civil Rights workers were murdered, especially.
Then I moved over to the Mississippi section.
How did monitoring work? Blacks should have been allowed to register to vote, but it often had problems. How were those things monitored?
Initially, when the early first efforts to register in most of these counties, the only people who were registered was the funeral director, maybe one or two teachers, people who were sort of up to the little who were well off.
But then, SNCC, the Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee and Southern Christian Leadership Conference, primarily SNCC, decided that they wanted to start a major effort in about 1961 before I came to the division.
Bob Moses was the person who was given charge of Mississippi. Even before I came, he had been beaten in a mid-county at one point.
The Civil Rights Division brought one of their first cases to stop. They were going to prosecute Bob for resisting arrest or interfering with a police officer.
Normally, a federal court does not get involved in state criminal cases. It wouldn't stop something like that because the old law was that you let you appeal a criminal case. You don't interfere with the state.
But that was one of the first cases that the division brought to stop the police officers to stop that prosecution from going forward.
So, Bob Moses then came to Greenwood, MS and moved this, they started a major initiative in the Leflore County, MS County to get people to register.
He and seven or eight other SNCC members who were encouraging people to go up and register were arrested and put in jail.
The division filed a lawsuit against the state of the Leflore County, MS County officials for their interference with these efforts to register people to vote under federal law.
One of my first trips to Greenwood, MS was there was a negotiated settlement which John and some officials carried out.
Remember going to the police station and getting those people out at getting Bob in a group of people out of jail.
It was a very courageous thing for any individual to go register who was black.
I mean, they were likely to lose their job. They were people knew who they were, especially in the more, even the more rural counties.
But in Mississippi, I think there's a picture here of a group going up to the Greenwood, MS steps if you're, if you wanted to see it.
I don't know whether it tells you anything more.
But these local officials were going to arrest, were going to do everything they could to, I don't know if the cameras still rolling out.
I showed it to you a while ago here.
I think this is a picture of blacks after, I think after they let the SNK kids out of jail, they came up, they were not going to interfere with doing all of it.
I'm not exactly on focus here.
Well, basically what we would do would be to try to find, we would go to these counties, locate the leaders in the community, and try to identify those blacks who had gone to register or were black.
Often times they'd go up there and they'd say, you've got to see the registrar himself or herself.
She's gone. When will she be back? Well, they'd leave work and they'd try maybe one or two more times and that was it.
The truth was they'd register people over the phone if they were white or if they were black.
They'd try maybe one or two more times and that was it. The truth was they'd register people over the phone if they were white or as John used to say if they'd lived and breathed, you could vote.
But if you were black, you were out.
Would they apply literacy tests or the thing?
Well, that was the ones who got there who were able to get in, were then given a section of the Constitution that they had to be able to read and write and interpret.
So the whole, all this litigation in all these states before federal judges basically involved the administration of the literacy test.
And we produced records that we would produce, we'd have the FBI go out, well, with the FBI then and we would find the people if we could who would attempt to register or were black.
Then we'd get the FBI to go with us into a registrar's office and we would photograph or the FBI would photograph under our supervision all the voting records in that office.
Then we would take them back to Washington and you could see on these records some of these people couldn't write at all that they were, we would try to identify those that were clearly illiterate or people you would see that numbers of people gave the same interpretation.
There's a provision in almost every constitution that says you can't, that there shall be no imprisonment for debt.
You can't put a prisoner well, they would say you can't put somebody in for dying death.
I mean there would be all sorts of totally incomprehensible interpretations by white people.
There would be blanks. They would be, there would be a requirement under the citizenship test that you sign your name in a certain place or something.
Which they would not require white people to do. I mean it was just totally off.
So the first major case in which this was stopped basically was in front of Judge Johnson and Montgomery, Alabama, in the Macon County, Alabama and Judge Johnson ruled that you had to apply,
they had to apply the same standards to blacks that they did for whites. So if you didn't require a white person interpret the constitution or correctly you're no longer going to have to do it.
It was called the freezing principle that the standard is frozen where it is applied to whites. Now not all the other judges.
Judge Johnson was really a beacon he stood by. He was probably the only federal judge for many years at the trial level. They had to protect him for these very fair, very strong orders that he issued in all these cases.
But in Mississippi we had Judge W. Harold Cox in Jackson on and most of the cases in the Southern District. Judge W. Harold Cox had been Judge Senator James O. Eastland's roommate I think.
He was an avowed segregationist and he would just put all sorts of roadblocks in your way. And we would try to get a motion heard to photograph records who would took two or three years to litigate that motion.
I would say the statute didn't mean what it said. So those cases proceeded very slowly and he would we would have to peel every order and contrary to Judge Johnson.
Judge Johnson he might say, oh this is discrimination against this person. I'm going to order you register these five people. I mean it just went.
So then we also filed the government civil rights division under with John and there were two or three other sectional leaders Civil Rights Division attorneys cohort who was from had gone to California to law school who was probably 80% blind.
I don't know the person. He had a monocular. He was a remarkable person, remarkable lawyer that we could talk about for a long time and Civil Rights Division attorneys cohort who ran the Mississippi section who came from Texas and fell in named Civil Rights Division attorneys cohort who was in charge of Louisiana.
Anyway, David came up with the theory that we should sue the state of Louisiana across the board and we sued. We brought.
The interuptial seconds. So within the division you had regional.
Right, we were all assigned. We were all geographical. So David, yeah initially Civil Rights Division attorneys cohort had Mississippi and what other places we were me. I think initially just had Mississippi and David had Louisiana and I was trying to who was Alabama?
See Frank had Alabama when I was in the Frank would I guess Frank had Alabama and Dave Norman had Louisiana. Those were the three and then it was Georgia and I worked for Dave. This worked for Civil Rights Division attorneys cohort and Mississippi.
And so then he assigned us by counties. So I was responsible for Leflore County, MS County and Greenwood, MS and then ended up also with Jackson and several other counties in Mississippi.
We would I mean we couldn't possibly do everything but like in Greenwood, MS at a voting case to a public and after the Civil Rights Act of 64 several public accommodation cases.
And police brutality cases. There was the yeah and we can talk about the cases. That's where met where the fellow shot men and grivers are from.
How many attorneys and researchers were in the division? How large was the division?
When I came I think there were 10 lawyers or 12.
For everything for the country. And now but it got larger as we grew when we had our seconds when our reasons for rights division reunion last year there were 400.
Now they have many more areas of responsibility but we did grow I think in Mississippi.
I mean it probably doubled or tripled while we were there. The joke was when you asked me about Robert F. Kennedy initially and he asked John Dore and Burke what the plan was early on after his office.
He said we want to the plan was we want to file one action in a significant county in every state for example. He said well we have to do we can't we've got to do more than that or one in each judicial district.
I forgot exactly what they wrote John has it in a book in a note that he's written.
He said we've got to have more lawyers and Robert F. Kennedy said well how many do you need and Burke Marshall said four.
We needed he thought that would be great if we could get four more lawyers. The problem was that the chairman of the judiciary committee was Eastland.
I mean there was these congressional committees were run by southerners and to think that you're going to get 30 lawyers or anything it was crazy.
And how many researchers were there when you got there and 65?
I think there were preceding me there were maybe three and then one left right away and then all together we probably see it's hard it's hard because you were 65.
We didn't meet like that we were on we were assigned different areas and we but I think that would probably 15.
Well after the big expansion came after the civil rights act of 1964 because the division then was responsible up to 1964 the only authority we had was to do voting cases and police brutality cases or conspiracy cases like the civil rights
workers case the liuzoo case but after.
I was going to ask about that so let's do that now and we'll talk about some specific cases but I was just going to ask the question how did the Civil Rights Act and the Voting Rights Act change the work that you did in the division.
Well from the first the first from until 1964 when I came in 62 and 63 virtually everything we did revolved around this effort the snake effort and the other efforts to get people to register to vote.
And so in almost every county we went to we would have these incidents we had the incident with Fannie Lou Hamer if you remember she and four or five other voting other workers of course she was from Rulval herself they were Mississippians came I'd been to a workshop on voter registration and stopped the bus stopped to win on a Mississippi Montgomery County and they will got off the bus and went to a lunch counter to get.
Something to eat and they were then arrested even though the interstate commerce commission had desegregated all those so they were arrested taken to jail beaten and.
For no reason at all and so we filed that was I think in March of 63 and so we filed a case a criminal information against the police officers and in September it was filed I believe in September the trial was in December but we had to it was a good example the FBI didn't really.
Like investigating these cases because they most of those agents grew up in that area they were friends with local law enforcement and they it was a segregated society and that's where they grew up they wanted south bank robberies so in this particular case we knew we learned from the report that there was a trustee in the jail turned out he was sort of a local drunk out of the city.
They were not forgotten his name whom they said they could not find the FBI couldn't find him we were had put this investigative file together and you were thinking about how when you trial how you're going to prove this case and so it happened that the day after president Kennedy the day that Oswald ruby shot Oswald I was coming down I was in.
Mississippi investigating that case looking for this trustee and I only had to talk to three or four members of the black community and what found out where he was I mean and so I drove to his house and he hadn't been happily hadn't been drinking but I asked him I came out and I showed him the photograph of these officers and these people was he there yes what happened and what did you do after the.
The meetings were over I mop the blood off the floor of the jail and will you test could you would you testify I'll testify and he did in December and it was a Friday afternoon it was a two day trial the second assistant civil rights division St. John Barrett no longer living put on the proof and I was and I helped.
I was in and they acquitted you probably know the acquitted the officers in about two hours and I ended up always remember this kind of ended up then driving over to sunflower county to see Mrs. Hamer and tell her that we lost but it was it was one of the first beginnings it was an all white jury's one of the few I think last all white jury's that came out of the box for the jury system was really well challenged in many of these.
County's course at that time there were hard very few blacks on the trial but then we had Mrs. Hamer's case and we had a heart.
You know I think she was I guess you have to say she was disappointed I think we had but I think they knew that we tried that the lawyers tried and we had become as I was going to say that they saw the
court that that they saw that there was a difference between the FBI and the lawyers for the sub rights division of the Justice Department and we were pretty much welcomed into the homes of black leaders all over in all these counties.
I mean after I got Bob Moses out of jail and SNCC had a place in they had an office in Greenwood, MS so I pretty well got to know those folks not that they loved me they wanted what they wanted was protection.
They kept saying why can't we have marshals or this is dangerous work can't we get a federal police force and if you read these books that's what they wanted was protection.
And we said where's our you know this that's not the way the system work we have to make local officials do what they're supposed to do that's what has to happen in this country.
And so I think always there is a reluctance in John describes this case after one of the other cases where the papers were drawn and they decided not to do anything against particular officials because we didn't want it to appear that any time we want to make them responsible for day to day maintenance of law and order in these communities.
Now that was very risky I mean you got the problem at Ole Miss you have all these violent these riots but eventually the system has to work and so after so that was 1963 all these in all these communities you had these various terrible things you had the civil rights workers murdered in 1964 but in 63 there was a number of these communities where you had these other heartman turn bow
and I'm sure this gets a little bit dreary I don't know I just.
Well the I think heartman turn bow had also in Holmes County taken people up to register to vote there was a fairly large community of blacks that was owned their own homes they had gotten land grants from I think Franklin
I mean from Teddy Roosevelt or some it was a historically this community called chula outside of homes outside of Lexington I think was a county seat of Holmes County it was also where Hazel Brannon Smith was a had a newspaper I have a little clipping on there from her she want to pule it so I think or a Nobel Prize for her reporting locally about these racial incidents.
Anyway heartman turn bow let have had let a group of people up to register to vote and they had a major voting rights thing underway and the plan I don't have all the facts in my anymore in someone through a fire bomb and shot into his house.
And torch his house and he was shooting back at these people as they went around the clans folks and they then turned out to arrest him for having set a fire to his own house.
So we filed a case to get him out of jail these are mean when I say we filed a case it probably took a week or two to get the case filed and once again the courts said the let the state court proceedings take care of this.
He was just a very dynamic local person who was willing to take on the power structure and willing to put himself out front to get these people registered.
The and I think I was mentioning the use Dutch turquoise about him in this book called working as a chapter about him.
I didn't spend that much time in Holmes County it was I happened to be next door when this happened so we interviewed a number I helped interview a number of the witnesses and get the case going but that was sort of the end of that.
But it was just another example there were all these in 1963 during the you could just see things heating up and of course the president was assassinated toward the Medgar Evers was assassinated.
So the Medgar Evers was killed and if you remember them after the Medgar Evers funeral these this group of blacks and the local police officers were about to have go against each other and it was John Doar who walked out into the street and Jackson Mississippi and you their photographs and I have clippings of him holding his hand out saying my name is John Doar D.O.A.R.
I'm from the Justice Department and everybody knows I stand for what is right and let's go back home and we won't have a riot this afternoon or whatever else but anyway that calm the crowd down and it was quite a gesture or quite a event.
It was quite a heroic thing for John to do but just to finish the voting rights thing what happens is you'd vote to take all these records back to Washington and you'd spend hours on a microfilm machine and we would categorize these by constitutional sections and by alphabet and we tried to arrange them in every possible way to show so that when we went to court we could show
basically the whites they let a literate whites register or if they gave them a constitutional section it would be very an easy section like that if you were black they'd ask you to define what rolling the long constitutional section setting forth the taxation of rolling stock of a railroad or some other really and very difficult.
But even with some of those long sections some of the teachers for example in Fort at the university teachers at the I think it was Alcorn or whatever is outside of Haddishburg Mississippi we had in that case the registrar forest blend they had we had held him in contempt of court for failing to register blacks
and at the last and one of our colleagues Gordon A. Martin Jr wrote a book about that Lynn case I've forgotten the name of it but I participated in the final trial which isn't mentioned in the book very much because Gordon had left but I always remember that we had an entire morning of these brilliant black teachers and educators who had been in the office
who had tried to register who had filled out numerous forms and written these very articulate interpretations and they were all turned down and so I think it was in fact in one of those lead cases the appellate court three judges came to far city and had a hearing and listened to this testimony for three days
and we're just so appalled by what had happened that they held him in contempt and you've got to register these people you can't do this and then he's sort of half listened and so he registered a few more people but it was always a few more I mean it was a very slow process so you could see that finally when you had this Selma to Montgomery March
I mean things just kept going and in 1964 after the murder of the Civil Rights Act what happened here at Quesson was what difference it made in 1964 the Civil Rights Act which Lyndon B. Johnson then promoted after the present Kennedy had gotten had been killed.
The division became responsible for enforcing the rights to employment school these aggregate school cases employment cases public accommodations were to be so in Greenwood, MS with public accommodations we had two theaters one of them belonged to a national chain out of New Orleans I've got the name of the chain
had a very nice fellow named Marshan who was a local person from Greenwood, MS who said okay the national chain said we're going to comply we're going to let blacks come into the theater like everybody else they can sit with whites so a group of blacks came to the go to the floor theater and Marshan let them in and gave sodom tickets and they went next thing you know they were beaten came back were beaten again the police were standing outside doing nothing
so we filed a lawsuit to against the police officers again and the paramount theater down the street was on locally they said we're not going to comply even though the law says we have to we're not going to do it until somebody really makes us so we filed a complaint against a suit against that theater to require them to desegregate eventually both cases were resolved in our favor there was an order against the police officers
and the police unfortunately I presented that case and I forgot where the trial was but one of the judges either got sick something happened or died and they had to point in new judge so it took a while to resolve them but they did I think after we filed things got a lot better so we had the that's just an example in the Leflore County, MS that kind of thing went on all over
and so the same thing and with employment cases and Jean worked on some fairly major employment cases
yeah the
but you talk just a little bit of background to help people who are who know nothing people don't know anything about the surprise move
what were the issues of jurisdiction why what was the relationship between the FBI and the Justice Department
what kind of what were the vectors of play in a more abstract sense and what could brought these issues to the front
well the FBI as it is today was the investigative agency in the Department of Justice and if I understand it right the attorney general is the chief law enforcement officer for the United States
and so in a sense the FBI is working for the Department of Justice the Department of Justice also has within it divisions for legal divisions to enforce the laws of the United States
the criminal laws laws against any truck the any trust laws civil cases that are everything from bank robberies all those other things that go on but in order when one those cases in order to evaluate those cases the FBI is asked to investigate them
so the local agents I mean the FBI also has its own breakdown for violent crimes but until the civil rights statutes came along most of what they were involved with were the things that you and I normally think about bank robberies, kidnappings the things that involve going across state lines
fraud of various kinds all these are violent crimes directed against the government agencies of some Oklahoma city or whatever but so civil rights and the enforcement of civil rights were you talking about societal change with something that was very difficult for a local white southern FBI agent to deal with because they grew up in that society
and they many of them believed segregation was a was the way of life that they were taught and so that's why it was so difficult but after you may remember in the investigation of the murder of the three civil rights workers it became fairly apparent that what we needed to really get into this that this was the culture of the FBI
that you needed to get FBI agents who were from other parts of the country to help do that investigation and and really to enforce civil rights laws and to to so that it wouldn't be the civil rights division lawyers that investigate their own cases that we were the one.
Well that's what happened in the voting cases that basically they might try at least the black community would trust us and finding one of my responsibilities in the civil rights worker prosecution was to invest to do a jury analysis back that was before they had jury experts of various kinds so I spent several weeks we did have a copy we knew would be in the larger jury pool might have been 80 people of which you know that would be the most important thing to do.
So we wanted to develop as much information as we could and by that time we knew many of the black leaders in the air in the area of those counties the number of really friendly whites was very few people like Hazel Brandt and Smith who ran that paper and there were others in the community there were always a some maybe a minister maybe a white family that was really important.
So I think it was well respected who at least would make some statements periodically or if they weren't always out front in order to live in those communities there were or newspaper editors the newspaper editor Hodding Carter was you know fairly well known as a newspaper that was willing to say it like it was those people were Hazel Brannon Smith's paper was bombed one day I mean these people was like
The Mountain Eagle down here all those folks had to show a terrific amount of courage and whether they could stay or not was another question I mean it's a my like Jerome A. "Jerry" Heilbron they basically chased him out of town.
So anyway I is that an answer you were looking for.
It's always time for you to do what you have to do it's job but I think it's pretty unique that it's to those civil rights division to civil rights cases more so than any others I think normally I mean I just read you and I
probably both read about the case in Boston with where they just convicted this guy Bulger who in the whole question was maybe you should pay off an age you can F.B.I. would pay off there was this link between the F.B.I. and the bad guys and I suppose that happens now and then but generally I think they're a very effective law enforcement agency and they do their job but this was very hard for them.
And it's not so there was a change that institutional change at some point to have non-Southern agents working at the right and I'm sure as that evolved that a new generation of whites grew up in many of those community where you probably do see some Southern agents and there was an agent in the civil rights case in meridian who was very key to the investigation and who
had who was in with the informants and who and who was really I think on the right side of things it was not the way quite the way Mrs. Ippie Bernie put it there wasn't that but this agent was straight he did what he thought he could do and then but the fellow who led the investigation is guy Joseph A. Sullivan had come down from the New York office he was had been in charge of the New York office I think and was the primary person in charge ultimately we have to do that.
I mean it was a long process to get that case through first they had a we had a grand jury and before there was an investigation before there was a confession and there were a number of the grand jury heard evidence that these local officials in the show but county had already engaged in quite a variety of some of police brutality cases that hadn't come forward and there were a number of other things that came out but we had to do that.
We had no confession and so there was no indictment the first time around and then they kept after it and finally got one and then two of confessions that ultimately led to the conviction of seven of these folks but the confessions come there was that federal or local court or whatever.
It was all federal no it was federal and well they weren't they wouldn't do anything it was pretty apparent they weren't going to do anything although eventually they did you know last year or about three or four years ago the jury hung on a preacher one of the masterminds of this case ironically was a minister named Killing who was in the clan and but the jury hung on him they were seven convictions.
And eight if I remember right either not guilty or hung jury verdicts and they hung on this guy killing and the state went after him several years ago and convicted him from of the murder and they did the same thing in the Medgar Evers case you know they had to try to
and that fell twice and so there was a good thing those things I think showed some progress but when we brought those cases the federal cases initially there was local law enforcement might as well not been there.
In fact it was right after that I think we before the murder of the three civil rights workers we had generally been a gun into these counties ourselves driven by ourselves as civil rights division lawyers if I was didn't have a second thought about driving around in Greenwood, MS or anywhere else after that so after those murders the civil rights division lawyers started driving in twos we were no longer alone I mean people were I think.
I think we were worried about their safety although I think we were generally didn't have to worry because people knew we were federal.
Did you ever run into any trouble?
Not really I always tell this I mean I always there is this incident I went up there was a case once in Yazoo County Mississippi which was not a case I normally was involved with but I was had the FBI photographing records we were going to look at the voting.
We had we may have already filed a case in Yazoo City but I had the FBI in one room they were file photographing records and the registrar was a guy named foot Campbell that was called foot Campbell and he wanted me to come in and talk to him he wanted to come in and chat with me and foot started telling me about all these lynchings that he had witnessed in his lifetime.
He decided he wanted me to know that he had been to several lynchings he was a segregationist there were some good blacks around but generally we why were making trouble with all these cases and he said let me show you something and he pulled a 38 out of his drawer and he shot it into the floor in front of my foot.
What the FBI in the next room?
You know but it he didn't shoot me it was just some sort of statement and the FBI came running you know if you this room that we were in this is about the size of a corner of our room so they if you heard it if you ever shot a 38 or if they're very noisy and so that was that was probably the only time that it was going to be a lot of work.
It's only a time that anything like that ever happened to me it's the only one I can ever identify as being and I wasn't really worried after that I said what are you doing?
He said I just want to show you this gun I wanted to show you what this gun could do some silly thing like that you know.
But we and the Yazoo City eventually was was I think we filed a case of Civil Rights Division attorneys cohort who became cheer of the chief of the housing section who's a judge that's another name for you he's a retired judge and now in Washington DC he's actually written a pretty good book that was never published that I had downloaded about his experiences.
His experiences in the civil rights division Schwelb SCH WELB and he's in DC he's had some health issues but it's it's bro I read the book within the last year.
So that that was the civil rights workers case of course John prosecuted that case as he prosecuted the liars the liars in case when you asked the voting rights act I know you can get to Jane you want to talk to Jane I'll tell you about the voting rights act really was the turn turn the
whole voting episode upside back where it ought to be the voting rights act abolished literacy tests the voting rights act set up a process in the southern counties based on a formula that allowed federal examiners to come in and register voters along with if the state officials were going to comply they could register voters if they signed their name.
With hardly any other technical requirements no more literacy tests so we then in we want to see many of these officials and local that would see that there was going to be compliance across the board.
The first major election one of the other counties I've been talking about Greenwood, MS but in Alabama Sheriff Sheriff Jim Clark Selma this it was no accident that they had this March from Selma to Montgomery March because Selma in Sheriff Sheriff Jim Clark the sheriff.
Sheriff Sheriff Jim Clark Sheriff Sheriff Jim Clark had been a poster child for segregationists and had and there had been serious attempts to get a major registration drives along the way and he had just been a bull walk against it in fact he and the local officials had for over a year.
They were just gotten in the way of every registration effort there were a group of students that came in to help register them and he got a cattle prod out and buzzed them and then arrested arrested them for resisting arrest.
These all these incidents were chronicled by an accord decision after John presented it to a federal court I think in December of 65 there was this case but Clark never really didn't and there was eventually an injunction against him but he was going to run for sheriff again in 1966.
The first primary election was scheduled from May of 1966 so there was real concern about how things were going to go. He was the first election in Alabama under the Voting Rights Act and I think the first day that they opened the offices like a thousand people registered in the various counties.
The total number of people who would normally voted in Sheriff Sheriff Jim Clark was around 7,000 after the Blacks registered after the Voting Rights Act there were 15 and almost all of the additional were the Black registrants.
This has all been written down in some respects but what happened in that case John was in Selma I wasn't there that day but I got there two days later.
The primary ballot had like 70 they were still using paper ballots in Selma and there were like 73 different things to mark.
This was also the first election in which there were Black voting officials they never had Black voting officials.
They were trying to be in the Black precincts very careful so at 4 o'clock in the morning all the other boxes had come back in to the primary, to the central place where they count the votes except in these five Black precincts.
So the election officials, the primary election officials who were white came out and they helped finish the count themselves and impounded the ballot boxes.
The next day they met and they decided and the Federal Federal at that point the next day they met and they looked at the boxes and they decided the best thing to do was just not include these.
They must be some fraud here because of these Black officials that took until 4 in the morning they didn't do this right and so we just won't include the boxes.
The result of that was basically the election had been very close between Sheriff Sheriff Jim Clark and his chief opponent Sheriff Sheriff Jim Clark who had been the safety director.
So actually in that counting two or three of the commissioners there were CPAs that reviewed these counts.
Two or three of them said you ought to count a couple of these boxes because we don't say anything wrong.
They said no. So we filed this case, the government, the Civil Rights Division filed a lawsuit to require them to count the ballots that had been legitimately filed by the voting by this group.
Well there were 17,000 votes, we counted every one of them. And Gene and Dorothy were part of that and so we stayed there for a week.
We filed this federal case, first we went to Judge Johnson whom I mentioned and they got him to issue an order that they could not, that they had to keep the ballots safe in boxes.
They couldn't do anything with it, they had to keep the ballots and protect them.
And then we filed Judge Johnson, the case was then assigned to Judge Thomas who was the chief judge in the Southern District.
He had kept the mobile school system pretty well segregated. They had appealed him every year and every year he'd had one more grade when they wanted to desegregate the schools.
They had appealed him to the fixed circuit and they said you've got to do more and he'd had one or two more grades.
So we were very worried about this judge before we were going to try this case. So we got to the trial and Gene and Dorothy had been watching these ballot boxes in the Sheriff's office.
And you were looking at ballots. Yeah I'm sorry, you were counting ballots.
We were doing it all. So...
Day after day, I mean thousands.
Yeah, I mean maybe they were the 17th.
Observed by Sheriff Sheriff Jim Clark's deputies who were trying to romance us and we liked to go to a crant clan rally and all this.
You know you're scared, you don't know what's going to happen or what they're going to...
And one of them gave Dorothy's, she still has Never" segregationist button. I was there, this guy's name was Buck. This big deputy chair of the kept trying to put the mic on Gene.
I went, we went into this little tiny room where all the ballots were. Well we put...
It's a button, it says never.
You know, the segregation button says never.
You thought that would win you over.
Of course, I don't know who knows what's going on.
Well Dorothy had it, I think he just thought this will give you a token of our affection because they like these two women who...
There's well, they've met that for a while.
Yeah, see, there's a bumper sticker.
That was in Bogalusa, LA but it was all over the South. Never.
I think it might have been Wallace's.
But...
Okay, thanks.
So the night...
Well we were getting all this proof together.
The night before John comes in and says, well John, you should put this case on, Carc and this John.
So I did.
So we had this trial for several days in front of Judge Thomas and we had federal observers.
At one point I wondered whether we thought we might have to put Gene on the stand but we didn't.
And to make a long story short, we had federal observers who had watched these various, the Countings and had been at the polls.
There were several hundred observers in Sheriff Sheriff Jim Clark that day at every polling place.
I mean they were really worried this way we were going to make sure as much as we could that this election would go right.
Because this was the first one.
This was the first one. It was the primary in Sheriff Sheriff Jim Clark.
So, Judge Thomas, we filed our briefs and Judge Thomas said there was nothing.
He saw nothing. No irregularities. Only minor irregularities if there were any.
And you shouldn't deprive the voter of the right to have his vote or her vote counted.
Even because of maybe some minor irregularity by an election official.
And though he ordered the votes to be counted and said there was actually an exception if the election officials found one or two ballots that were, if there was something wrong, they could discard those ballots but he had to find them.
But they didn't. So he ordered them. This was too much for him.
The right to vote was very important. Even for this Judge who would let held on with, kept the school system segregated for a long long time.
So that was a big win. That was the first one on the voting rights case.
Now you remember probably back to 64. There was after the March not 64 but the March from Selma to Montgomery March.
You had this Viola Viola Liuzzo situation who had, she had come down from...
Or Ohio from somewhere near Detroit as a person of conscience who wanted to help.
And she and this young black man were taking driving.
She was going to give a ride back to somebody to Montgomery and the clan, of course, shot and killed her that day.
And there were several other incidents of violence around the March that happened.
I mean the whole, the injunction, again, the government went to Johnson for an injunction to protect the marchers.
I think the message is, I think, that the legal system, the judges, the work that the division did, was pretty substantial.
I mean, this was a significant case, the Sheriff Sheriff Jim Clark case.
And the whole effort to get the voting rights act of 65, the principles of that act, came out of those earlier cases I was describing to you, the freezing principle,
the notion that you can't use a literacy test to pry somebody the right to vote.
Now the Supreme Court this year recently turned some of that upside down, saying that everything is okay today.
Even though there was all this testimony during the congressional hearings that said there was plenty of reason to keep the act going.
So what was your response to that, to that recent ruling given your experience, both of you given your experience then?
Well, I mean, I think the minority is right. I think Justice Ginsburg is right.
I think they should have, they shouldn't have decided the case that way.
And we heard Hillary Clinton at the American Bar Association spend a substantial amount of her time saying we've got to do something to turn that case around.
Now whether it's congressional work or lawsuits that are going to be filed in some of the cases, you saw in a number of these states that they immediately started coming out with voter ID laws or other kinds of statutes laws that are obviously intended to turn the clock back.
And make it more difficult for people, minorities to register to vote, that kind of thing.
So I think it was quite, I'm sorry that I feel bad. I feel bad. I mean, I think the court, the decisions wrong, but you got, I don't agree with Bush v. Gore either, but that's our system.
And we don't go into the streets. We start working on trying to change it.
We did interviews in Boglosa with the Robert "Bob" Hicks and all. They were doing testing of the Civil Rights Act. Were you involved in any of that? Or was that?
Well, I'd have to go, they were doing testing of at restaurants and public accommodations and that sort of thing. Well, this paper, these pictures, well, you did the never one, one of these pictures is these folks were picketing and he's getting doused by the local barber.
And this picture of, this is James Farmer leading the March.
I hadn't remembered the Robert "Bob" Hicks, but I guess that's, they were leading the March of local blacks who were trying to
support the testers and to get these stores to comply and employers to comply.
This is a similar view except it has two lawyers. One of them is Lou Couter and the other is John Rosenberg when we were at that March.
Often the Civil Rights Division lawyers were the buffer between the police and the demonstrators and this, it was a, uh, uh.
And why, why was that?
I mean, you marched purposely for that reason. No, I went, why were we here? No, we weren't really, I guess we were there to kind of we were observing.
So, which we did a lot of with the observing or interviewing so that we could gather information. I, that was the, I was saying I spent about a month in Boca-Lusa helping to put this case together.
A lot of it was FBI work, but there were just a series of incidents directed against local blacks who were, as you say, either testing or trying to get stores and restaurants to comply.
And, um, it seemed to me one of the incidents involved a very liberal senator from Arkansas Brooks Hayes who was supposed to come and give a talk.
Eventually didn't, and there were the, the clan came out with a bunch of threats and leaflets and he decided he wouldn't come. He was afraid.
But so, core organized a protest march that was fairly large.
Um, and, uh, this, it was really, we were observing these marches. Blue was there for a while. I don't, I didn't remember. I don't know how long he was there, but I spent almost a month together.
And then at the end, I went to see, uh, we put the case together and went to Judge John Judge John Minor Wisdom. I always tell people when you, when you go to law school, you're one of your early courses is called equity or remedy.
And the history of equity is that, um, it was a change in the law from just being able to get damages and to, to the, the courts with, the equity courts had a chancellor who could stop bad behavior.
You could, and if you needed to writ, you supposedly could go, this goes historically, you could go see the chancellor even in his night shirt so that you could get a relief.
And that, so in my clan case, I always remember I went at that time, the fifth circuit had its main offices in, was in New Orleans and the old fish and wildlife building.
And at the time, I don't think there was even a good air conditioning system. So I went looking for a Judge John Judge John Minor Wisdom, Judge John Minor Wisdom on a Saturday. It was hotter than blazes.
I finally found Judge John Judge John Minor Wisdom in the back in his office and he was sitting there in his undershirt. And so I went to Judge John Judge John Minor Wisdom and said, Your Honor, we have this petition, we have to get a preliminary injunction against the plan for, to stop these activities.
I mean, we would need a trial, but in order to get things underway, you have to get him to sign this order. And so he did, and so I always think that I went to see some people saw the chancellor in, in his night shirt, I got an injunction from Judge John Judge John Minor Wisdom in his, in his undershirt.
He was hotter than he was perspiring. I later got an award in his name, but I never, and I, and he escaped before I could get him to sign the program.
But keep looking at, I know it's in there.
What are you looking for? I thought the hose picture from both sides.
Oh, yeah, I'm sure it's here. There were, there are a couple of these pictures that, and I think this is a different picture of the March.
That's the Edmund Pennis Bridge.
So, Johnny, you weren't, you weren't worried about your safety too often between, did you worry about him or about yourself?
Well, we were not, you know, at that time I wasn't married to him.
What you like? So, I did like him. Yeah, I did like him.
There were time, there it is. There were times when I was really frightened.
And we've had some pretty unpleasant incidents, because of course I was in primarily in Alabama in those early years, and we never knew if we needed to seek,
go into a restaurant, what would happen? You know, our water would get spit in and that stuff.
We would get that kind of treatment. And you never knew whether that was going to escalate.
I mean, now when you look back you think, oh, how safe we were, but we didn't feel that safe.
And I remember once, we worked very hard, and on the Meredith March, I was the traveling connector between the attorneys who were in the field.
With the March, walking with the marchers and the attorney general.
And they would report to me and I would report to him.
And we worked until like 10 and 11 at clock at night, and I remember one of the attorneys and I decided we'd just take a walk.
I was in Yazoo City, Mississippi, and we'd just take a walk around the block.
And we got about a quarter of a way around the block, and all of a sudden this car pulls up behind us, screeching,
and people jump out and they start following us. And George, who is from Mississippi, said, now, Gene, just keep looking straight ahead and keep on walking.
And I remember when you're frightened like that, your feet feel like you're walking through mud.
But we made it back to the hotel and nothing happened. But we didn't know.
And so we felt very vulnerable sometimes.
I thought you were going to remember after the lowest race, one of the first black secretary in Selmo.
In our office, we opened an office, the Civil Rights Division, in his later years, started opening out of few offices outside of Washington.
And the first one was in Selma, Alabama. Later there was one in New Orleans, and the lawyer who's in charge of the office who lived there, in Selmo was Chad Quaintance.
He's in Minneapolis, and after he left the division, he went to a large law firm in Minneapolis, and then he semi-retired and went to Divinity School, and never became a minister, but he's been teaching religion.
He taught religion at Hanover College, and said some eyesight problems, but they are.
And so he's one of the folks who spoke on that particular event and talked about it, one of his Alabama cases.
But he also mentioned Blowest Reese, who is this secretary in Selmo, now many years later, of course, but she's still living.
But we had worked together very, very hard preparing a big massive school desegregation case, and making in Alabama.
What did you want to do?
No, it was the league against making it, and that's when we were up for three days and nights, straight around the clock.
And she was a small town, she came from Selmo, we were in Montgomery, and she was my roommate.
And after the third day, when it was finished, we went, and now it had big meal, and then we went back to the motel room, and she had run out of her epilepsy.
But she didn't know how, you know, I now know living here in a rural setting that you don't necessarily think first about calling back to the pharmacy, or I mean, I can understand why she didn't try to get a refill.
But she had a grandmaw seizure.
That's a good idea.
And I called for help, I called the desk, and asked for an ambulance, because I didn't know what I was seeing at that time.
And when the first ambulance came, they saw she was black and they wouldn't take her.
So I was really upset then, because I didn't know what, and she was, she was, her seizure lasted a long time.
And so I called John, who was in another room, and I said, I can't get an ambulance, you have to help me get somebody to take to the hospital.
And so finally we got an ambulance, and we went to the hospital, and they treated her for about, once she, they got her conscious, and she said that she had epilepsy.
I don't know what they did, because I wasn't in the emergency room, but they said, okay, now you go home. We went home.
And then of course she had another seizure.
She had another seizure.
And so it was a hard, it was a hard lesson in how unequal, I mean I'm sure she'd been white, they would have kept her.
It was a terrible experience. Have you ever seen a grandma seizure?
It's unbelievable. You think somebody's dying right in front of you?
I figured after that, we might as well get married.
I thought, actually after I left on that trip, actually that's a personal story, inside our personal story.
So then we went home, right? But I didn't get, John didn't get to go home. I had some vacation coming.
At home at that time was Philadelphia, where my folks were.
And so I took hopped the plane in Montgomery to go to Philly, and John got ordered to, you know, the guy that did Julius LeVonne Chambers to the clan?
They'd bombed Julius LeVonne Chambers house in Charlotte.
I think John also knew I was from Gastonia, NC next door.
But my family was in Gastonia, NC.
So he sent me to Charlotte to investigate. We didn't know, we actually ended up going for a grand jury.
Because there was some clan activity in Charlotte. I mean, they were after Julius, and fortunately it wouldn't hurt.
But the same fill I was telling you about with about the Carroll County, MS case, Nicholas deB. Katzenbach? — actually probably Nick Katzenbach?.
I don't know how it happened, but he was in Charlotte to help me do this investigation, where we ended up in front of a grand jury.
But Nick and I, during the, we were at lunch two days later.
And I said, Nick, we were going, standing in line to go to lunch, there was a rest of the long line.
I said, Nick, I'm going to, I'll be back in a minute. I'm going to call Jean. I think I'm going to ask Jean to marry me.
That was the Charlotte trip. She'd gone back to Philly and I was in Charlotte.
My family in Gastonia, NC is just 20 miles away from Charlotte. It was kind of like going to Pikeville, KY.
And so anyway, I called up and spoke to her and spoke to her mom and dad.
And what next day they were on the road to Gastonia, NC.
My family may not know everything, but they figured out really quick that marrying somebody with a German name, they better, they better present themselves before John's parents immediately so that they could say it.
They could say it, establish rapport before.
Well, it's just a little sidebar, but that's what, that's actually what happened.
But proposed her over the phone. We'd worked hard. I thought if she put me through this.
No, we know what you're doing with somebody, you really get to know them. And so it wasn't a big surprise.
And the whole thing, it's like being a battle.
Yeah, probably true.
Or in the military, you're on something. There was a lot of hard people working really hard for.
For, you know, for.
Principles, I believed in.
How did you keep yourself going? Was it exhausting work? How did you?
I think it just people in the civil rights division. Everybody worked.
Everybody from the top from John door to, to the secretaries.
I mean, everybody did what needed to come next.
And we did the very best we could all the time because we knew.
It was important to do the very best you could all the time because we were, this was history.
You knew you were living history.
And there were some divorces along the way.
There were hardships.
That was very hard on the wives at home.
Yeah, I mean, if you're responsible.
But it was, I think you're just going up hell a lot against these judges.
And you just knew like with the Judge W. Harold Cox, you knew that you were going to have to appeal.
And you're going to go to the next and so it was called making a record.
You wanted to put this case together because you knew you're probably going to lose.
So when the next court looked at it, they would say, he, this is wrong.
Right.
And you're going to reverse that judge.
So you had a sense of the long haul of them.
Well, you wanted it to come around to what you were thinking.
It was going to be a long haul.
And I think in that way, the, if you look at the history of the Voting Rights Act and the testimony from Kat,
I guess Katzmacken, these other people who testified, they basically had said, this is not going to work in just one case at a time.
We are, we are doing the best we can through the courts.
But blacks are entitled to vote and we need to have it happen.
Right.
And so Martin Luther King that marched all together.
And so I think the, the cases had a real place.
I mean, it was like the first attack.
It was the first law.
It was a launch.
And, and I think the division in the department, the attorney general, they deserve great credit for that.
It's not a story everybody knows.
I mean, it didn't, the movement, I mean, the relationship might have been better, but Bob Moses knew that he could call John any hour.
He might say, no, or he might say, we can't, I only have eight lawyers who can't send them all to LaFlora County or next door.
They developed a relationship and I think actually a life long relationship, even afterwards.
You know, Bob became well known for this algebra project.
He's been become an educator and we've seen him a couple of times since then.
And Lawrence Guyot, you know, you know, you know, some of these names and many of them we knew and saw very often.
But I think you could see that, I mean, that was enough to keep, I mean, if you knew Fannie Lou Hamer or Mr. Eskridge,
and she's out there chopping cotton or thinking she might lose her job or Eskridge is set all out there by himself,
he wants just all he wants is to get his kid into school, which certainly is not the most popular thing to do.
I mean, he's really, they're putting their lives online.
I don't think, I never felt like we were putting our life on the line.
I mean, I think you've got that little yellow, you've got that black thing in your pocket.
This is one, I would just happen to see it, it was the one that has me up front.
But you know, you've got that little black thing in your pocket is the Justice Department ID, which people I think knew.
I mean, most of these rural counties, they figured you were either an insurance salesman or you were a Justice Department lawyer.
It goes, you're in a suit and tie.
Yeah, I mean...
But some of the civilized workers dressed well, too, at least, at certain point.
Yeah, I don't think they were too conscious, but they certainly didn't look.
I mean, they were students from all over.
I was thinking when you just mentioned that we had this case in Itta Bena, MS, the black section in itabina,
which is outside of Greenwood, MS, what, Leflore County, MS?
Black section is known as Balance Do.
Had you read it? You're shaking your head.
I was one of those doing some research, yeah.
I mean, they had a, they were in the church night after night, this group, and somebody threw a smoke bomb into the church.
So they go to the deputy sheriff, they take all of the church, the whole group goes up to the deputy sheriff's house.
It's night time.
They arrest them from 15 to 80.
The oldest person was 80, the youngest 15.
They took a meant jail the next morning.
I think it was the next morning, that maybe two days later, they tried them in groups of ten.
What was the chart?
They were disturbing the peace.
Like going to the...
Yeah, going to the church.
And I don't have the pictures of it.
They're finally lost it to get them out to try to...
And they sent them all, they all find them all, I think, $500, and they sent them to 30 days in jail, the county farm.
All of it, a few days later, they let some of the really older people out.
The guy's name was Artie Burr, but we filed this case, and John put me on the stand to talk about,
I sat there and watched them convict all these people, this justice of the peace.
And so we filed that case, and actually eventually we...
That was for Judge Clayton and we lost.
What happened in the meantime was the National Council of Church has got some bond money, and got these people out.
But I went up there every day to that penal farm to interview these people for about two weeks.
But they were sitting there in terrible shape.
For no reason at all.
I mean, it's kind of like these things you see in other...
Nobody was killed in that situation, but it was...
It would never happen if you were white, if that was a white group, never in your life at that time.
This was 63 again.
I mean, they're just all these incidents that ended up leading up...
I mean, at some point Congress had to do something.
And they did.
And Johnson, I mean, this...
And the people who drafted that.
So here's the...
This was the Bogalusa, LA barber spraying water on one of the protesters who was there to help during that case.
Were you there, Jean?
In Bogalusa, LA?
Yeah, you may very well have.
It's still running as a barber shop.
He would cut hair for blocks.
Ray Mowray.
Well, that poster, courage.
Have you seen that one?
Where they...
That was this...
Maybe that was Bogalusa, LA.
I never knew.
I haven't in the other room. That's why I know it.
Where... I know that we're about on the anniversary.
So I wouldn't ask about the march on Washington.
Where were you in the field when that?
I was in Washington during that little period.
I was thinking about all the 63 stuff.
I was there and I was in the Department of Justice watching the march.
Our office was on the first floor.
So I think I went outside and watched some of it.
I didn't get up to the speakers.
It was actually a work day.
I was in Miss Hamers case.
What was the date?
It's now.
What was the date of the march on Washington?
It would have been now, right?
Yeah, it's in a couple weeks.
I think it was just during a little interim period that I was in Washington and saw the march.
But it was really a work day.
Unless you took off to be part of that.
But I do remember the march.
You had a role to play later on when they had the city.
During the Washington riots.
Right before then when they had the...
Resurrection City?
Oh, yeah.
I mean, we were again.
It was one of those observer working in between things.
Marian Wright Edelman, who's head of the Children's Defense Fund was negotiating with John.
How long can we stay?
They were going to stay there and try to get some of their demands met and on voting.
What was that the aftermath, too?
Do you remember the Resurrection City?
Did that follow?
Is it Portable's campaign?
I get these mixed up, so I'm not sure.
I was trying to remember it seemed like it came right after something.
But we were...
I mean, the riots were right before,
right after the Nixon came into office.
The big... because John N. Mitchell...
Well, no, there were...
I was thinking about the riots.
I was thinking about the inauguration I was on the street through Nixon and Mark.
We had quite a number of people out with Mitchell.
At that point, we weren't going to stay much really...
Trying to ensure that that was going to be a safe process.
During the riots...
What's after King's assassination?
It was after Martin Luther King was killed, right?
1968.
Now there...
I worked Nicholas deB. Katzenbach? — actually probably Nick Katzenbach?, the same fellow I mentioned earlier,
and he and I went to Memphis, and we prepared the extradition papers to get Ray, James Earl Ray,
back to this country from England.
So I remember getting these affidavits.
You all just came from Memphis.
We were just there, we just went to the museum.
The New... so right's museum?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a one that was quite impressive.
And they added a section since we were...
You and I went to the first one, right?
They added a whole new section, I think, which I haven't seen yet.
They're building a huge new wing right now, 27 million dollars.
Really?
But they've got all the state's evidence on display.
Oh, really?
I mean, this was towards the very beginning,
so we were getting affidavits from police officers and fingerprint people.
I'm looking at the gun and what we needed was enough information together to get him extradited back to this country.
I think the extradition papers were really prepared in Washington by some...
but he and I went down and we got all this information together.
And then built to you in the Civil Rights Division?
Interesting.
Now, I think probably the Attorney General's office may have put the case pieces together,
but they wanted us to do that.
They wanted me and I don't know where we were at the time.
Maybe in the Carroll County?
No, it was 68.
And then after that, I remember when these rights in Washington, Cyrus R. Vance, was my boss.
I mean, he wasn't at the Civil Rights Division, but he was secretary of something.
And I spent a lot of time with him for a couple of days trying to...
they were arresting a lot of people, you know, and they were sending him to a place in...
Marlund, Quantico?
We were quite a little vague, but for me, some of the division was very much involved in that again.
I think again, partly because the protesters and the black activists knew that they were going to get a fair shake.
People were going to be respectful and appreciate what they did, but that we had a job to do.
And Jean mentioned the poll tax case a while ago.
I just don't know how much you want to say about that, but the...
you know, the poll tax was another one of those reconstruction act things that required people to pay, cheer, to be able to...
as a condition of voting.
And then it was cumulative over time and was only throughout the South.
It was another device to prevent people from registering to vote.
So the legislation that implemented the Voting Rights Act, there had been one case that had been...
I think one of the Lawyers Committee might have filed a case, but anyway, the Voting Rights Act of 1965 required the Attorney General to forthwith file an action to contest the poll tax in the Southern States.
And we had those cases ready to go, and on the Monday, I went down on the Monday after the act was signed.
I went to miss to Jackson and filed the poll tax case in Mississippi.
Turned out, I ended up working and preparing the Alabama poll tax case.
And Stephen J. Pollak, who was by then the Assistant Attorney General, was maybe his first assistant still before he became Assistant Attorney General.
I think so. He argued the case.
So we put all these cases together and we basically had this history of segregation, all the segregation statutes.
The interesting thing in that Alabama case was that...
and this is in the opinion that the court issued, just before, even after we filed this case, there was an election coming up locally, a statewide election.
And Governor Wallace had a brochure printed with his picture on it that went...
that the highway patrol went all over Alabama, distributing it to all the white schools to take home to their parents.
Not only to the white schools. I mean, this is done after we filed this case.
So we put it in the record. And if you open the opinion, you see this brochure with Wallace's picture on it describing this thing.
Even down to the right before trial, they were going to do everything they could to prevent blacks or at least to maximize the white election and electorate.
And so there was all this history. We had this legislative history of all these terrible remarks made by the legislators way back in 1900.
The only reason we need to stop these blacks from voting.
I mean, it's so... there's no hidden language. I mean, it's very emphatic.
And then, all the way forward, describing the statistics. But then the court invalidated the poll tax in all of these states in two or three different cases.
But it was another... and it was, again, the result of all this litigation that had come along. I mean, where we had all this information and that had come.
But it was another big... it was a nice case that has spent a good bit of time on. And it had been a case before Judge Johnson, Fred Gray, who is a prominent black attorney and Montgomery still.
If you have an... he's really a terrific person. He filed a case contesting one of the elections right after...
which, I think, was really a local election. And I represented the government that Judge... what Judge Johnson started to do was in most of these civil rights cases, whether the government brought it or not, he would order the government to...
the United States to be made a party because he wanted the civil rights division lawyers in his court.
John or one of his representatives. So, I... this was not a case that had a particularly good outcome, but I sat there with Fred Gray probably for...
I think this case took two or three weeks of putting on testimony about the election and the getting all the statistics in.
And we were advising the court this best we could about what to do. And in the end, if I'm... in the end, I think all that came out of it really was...
maybe some reforms in the way they were supposed... they would needed to carry out their election process.
But the election itself, if the officials was not overturned, but it was Fred's in that case that he had brought, but got to know him pretty well.
But Judge Johnson was really... you talk about a hero, you asked about the...
And so, so we're all... all of these judges, Judge John Judge John Minor Wisdom and Judge John R. Brown and Judge Griffin B. Bell, who was from Atlanta, eventually went to the 11th Circuit.
He was the Attorney General. He was trying to think who the other Circuit Judge judges were.
That were on that 5th Circuit.
I just can't remember all their names, but it's... sure was a blessing to have them on the court at the time, because so many of these district judges were southerners who were...
who made it very difficult to litigate in front of them, and it took so much longer, or the same thing in Louisiana, except for Judge Johnson, same thing in Northern Alabama in the Birmingham District, because you had these...
a Northern and Southern Arneastern and Western District Federal Court in each one of these states, as we have today.
And so, putting these initial trial records together was invariably for the next court, and it was a slow process.
But it really, in the end, it really made the record for the Voting Rights Act. I mean, it's quite a story, and that sense, Brian tells that history in his book really well, I think.
Did you have a permanent residence during these days, or were you... I mean, it sounds like you're in the field most of the time.
We lived in Washington. When we went to Houston, we moved to Houston for six months, because that was going to be a fairly large case.
But in the 60s, even before Gene came, we were probably gone. John described, it's interesting in this Florida law of you note that he wrote some years ago.
He said, he'd go outside on a Friday. You could see the briefcase was lined up outside the Civil Rights Division offices.
And back then, people would get on the plane. They'd either go to Memphis or Birmingham or wherever they were going.
And the airplane were the DC-3s. Remember, there were C-46s in the Air Force, or C-47s, I guess.
And they'd take off on a Friday afternoon for two weeks, and we'd go down and usually photograph several counties,
we would have made the arrangements to get the FBI in, and you try to photograph four or five counties.
I also did the Jackson Heins County, that's Jackson, with photographed all those records.
And I know they remember, they had a courthouse in Rankin, I think it's a name of the town, not only in Jackson, but you're looking at thousands and thousands of records.
And then in some of them, in some of the larger cities like Jackson, some blacks had gotten registered to vote.
But again, it was not carte blanche. If you knew you, or they'd have to register some, and get a little more sophisticated, then it would in the rural counties.
But we would all have responsibilities for several of these voting cases at once, and some of them, as they came to trial,
the first John tried many of these cases himself, and Civil Rights Division attorneys cohort tried the case, and eventually those of us, the line lawyers, grew up a little bit under this system.
It's a very disciplined system, and in the government, you write a complaint, and you send it up to the next person who redlines it, and sends it back to you, and you gradually is, I mean, and the, yeah.
So we learned to be pretty good lawyers under that system. I mean, I always tell people, so I think it stood me really in good stead when we came here, because I had to teach one to teach another group of lawyers how to deal with that.
And we'll probably just take another 10 minutes or so.
So I went close to the final.
Oh, no, I was just thinking about when he said they really over-prepared every case, and visualized the Houston school system.
We took, and color-coded, on maps of Houston, every single residence in the enrolled student, to show how the lines were, it was just, you just can't not imagine how labor intensive.
That was before computers. I mean, it was just amazing.
We would call them dot-maps. You know, blacks had, we're red, and whites were green, and we showed where the schools were, and they were busing black student packs, white schools, and white schools pass black schools.
Houston was, and that case had gone on for many years, and Judge Ben C. Connally, we had four or five lawyers working with me, plus how many research analysts?
It was kind of like an antitrust case, foot lockers of records, and the Houston school case going way back, and what we wanted was busing to try to remedy the effects of this panel.
The effects of this past discrimination, and try to get some reasonable integration into the Houston school system, because the inner city black schools were pretty bad.
They spent all their money out in suburbia. The problem, one of the problems was you had this black core, and then you had the beginnings of a donut around it, of Spanish speakers.
And so some of the parent, and then you had white suburbia. And so how do you really fix that? Judge Ben C. Connally in the end paired up a lot of schools. Many of them were black and mixed Spanish speakers, Chicano.
But then they appealed that, I think in the end, the court of appeals, we were gone by then, required some busing.
But I think the best thing that happened was that the voters threw the school board out, and they threw out this lawyer on the other side, and that had happened in many places.
This lawyer became a millionaire off the school case. I mean, he was a corporate lawyer, but they'd been resisting desegri in his school system for years, and this lawyer had made a living off that really for many years.
And the same thing in Little Rock, I had a couple of cases in Arkansas. This big firm in downtown Little Rock, representing these school districts, these rural school districts that were still totally segregated.
And they were, I mean, they did other work, but they were well paid to keep the system segregated. And so in Houston, they finally ditched him, and they had a whole new school board.
And I think that over time, Houston, I mean, it's an enormous system. Now it's twice as big as it was when we were there.
But I think they've really reformed them on their schools. But those are different. Same thing with employment cases. I mean, we haven't mentioned them.
When we started when I became chief of the Western section, we sued the electrical workers in Las Vegas, because the union was, blacks couldn't get a job.
You couldn't get into the apprenticeship, couldn't get into the union because you were black, which you hardly ever realized. And it's still pretty much a segregated town.
I mean, the housing patterns, we sued the steam fitters in Los Angeles, sued the roadway express. That was James Case, roadway trucking company with my, well, they were in Birmingham, right?
Yeah, they were in Birmingham.
Yeah, but the division, the same thing with schools afterwards. There were a lot of schools in Indianapolis, schools in Oklahoma City as the, as the after the Civil Rights Act of 64, the division really expanded its work into other parts of the country as well.
I mean, it was not on, it needed to happen because the all segregation didn't just happen in the South. It might have been more de facto in some areas in the larger, much more difficult to do the Chicago school case or Indianapolis.
So let's use this as a segue then into your move out of out of the division and to hear and the work that you took on here and this idea of taking on other social justice issues and how these maybe related one to the other.
Well, I mean, I think they are, as they are related. I mean, we hoped we could, I guess I was hoping that I could continue doing public interest work. I did talk to some private firms, but we went on this big camping trip and wasn't quite sure.
But we left the division because the administration changed and the cases that got filed, what congressional district they were in seemed to become more important than what was in the case.
Well, and they retreated on school, these are the issues. I mean, I think it not an easy decision and there was some civil rights division lawyer revolts. I don't know if you remember, there was some of that history when they felt that the division wasn't doing enforcing the law the way they should.
And actually that took most of the half of my way were in Houston. So, but whether it belonged to, if you are going to leave, especially if you're in a position of some responsibility, whether they're going to fill your shoes with somebody who is not going to do the kind of work at the level that you were doing it.
People who are really committed should you stay and fight it out and try to push him to do that or can you.
But we decided also because I think if you stay in government service, you sort of start pricing yourself out of the mark. I mean, you're making fairly good money. You're doing fairly good economically too.
And if you're going to switch, of course we took a big die, you know, we took our money. It's only half.
Well, we came here, but we do, you know, we decided money wasn't all that important to us.
Were you tired too? Did you need a break from that taste or not?
Well, we went on this camping trip for three months with a little baby. Went to Canada and went to all the national parks.
I mean, we sort of left in the beginning of the summer and decided then we formally didn't leave, I think, when we came back.
But we went on a put up a tent or learned how to put up a tent in New Jersey, which we bought at a Morse end store.
And then we went up to the state, up the coast, up the New End, up to Canada.
We took probably a couple of months and our Michael was what, three, four, he was six months old.
Jean was breastfeeding. And we just got away from it. And right after we left one of the firms, one we come back for an interview.
And I said, no, we didn't want to do that. But along the way, one of our colleagues, Terry F. Lenzner, who is,
a book is going to come out, who also was at that point, the director of legal services for the Office of Economic Opportunity for OEO.
And they had started some legal services programs with OEO money. There wasn't a lot of that going.
Most of those programs were in the Northeast where, at that time, under the Office of Economic Opportunity Act, you could only get a project if the governor agreed.
You had to stay, you had to stay, you had to stay okay for whatever happened. And so there were a few legal service programs outside of the Northeast, California.
So this, Terry had been approached by some lawyers in Charleston who once started public interest law and was public interest law firm focused on the coal issues, symptomatic issues of poverty and the coal fields.
And so he got in touch with us and said, why don't you go down and take a look at this. I would like, I'm willing to put a little money in starting supporting this kind of work in Appalachia.
And so we came down, we stopped and visited with folks in Charleston, and then we came down here, camped out here at Jenny Wiley State Resort Park, put the tent up.
Jean said you better see if there any bears around. Foxes, they're wanting somebody out there but us. I mean, it was at the end of the season.
I figured if there were animals that were eating off the campers and there were no more campers.
So we did, we were actually on our way to Florida. It was high holidays. Jewish high where we were going to go.
To my parents who had retired to Florida. So we came down here and we interviewed Harry, Harry M. Caudill and Whitesburg, KY who wrote, night comes to the Cumberlands and was on.
He was on the Appalred Board and was Virginia that already started a little corporation up there.
And just for the record Appalred stands for Appalred.
That was the original name and several years later when we had to split the programs because of political problems.
I mean, we weren't welcomed down here anyway. So we came here and we, the Prestonsburg, KY, we came to Prestonsburg, KY.
We came to Charleston and talked to the folks who were there that Terry had talked with.
And then there were, there was some lawyers who were unlicensed who were already here and then fell on him to Howard Thorkelson.
And Howard was going to leave and they asked us to, he was going to be the deputy for Westford for Kentucky.
Anyway, so he was leaving. So we came to Prestonsburg, KY and then drove down to Whitesburg, KY to talk to Coddle and said, we'd think about it and drove and drove on down to see my parents and the real thought was there, there are some real environmental issues, there are some poverty issues.
There are certainly a lot of poverty and there are very few lawyers who are going to, who appear to be available to challenge these.
Most of these private attorneys were tied up by co-companies and the issues that were described to us by Harry, this broad formed deed and the environmental issues around strip mining and coal mine health and safety, Black Long.
And the poverty issues consumer law and there were a lot of, at that time there were a lot of basic issues around food stamps and Medicaid and the early parts of that program applicants were given a very, had a difficult time.
Local time, just local welfare offices were very, very negative and were not very, they weren't working with the NIGG ARDO.
Anyway, it was just, how could your dad spelling?
Oh no.
They were just terrible, I mean, they, they, they, you would think they were treating these applicants so badly and people were having a difficult time getting food stamps.
Very, very much the same.
Food family were.
Who you got and jobs were all very political because the coal that only two industry, the largest employer invariably in these counties was the co-companies and the second largest were the school districts.
And they were very politicized and there was much of a fiefdom as we saw in the white power structure in the, in the south.
But I think, you know, what, what was your area that you covered?
Well, we started, I mean, technically the organization was for the Appalachian counties in Kentucky, of which there were 42.
We subsequently gave, gave away, we gave moved six counties into another legal services programs, the ones around Ashland.
But the program covered these 37 counties and so when, when I first came, we had one or two, we had an office on the campus University of Kentucky when in Barbaraville and here.
We eventually, when the Legal Services Corporation Act was passed and finally there was federal funding.
There was a lot of controversy about the legislation to create a structure for free legal services programs, a lot of opposition.
When we came to here, there was a lot of opposition from the local bar because they thought we were taking money away from them.
And the community because they thought we were communist?
Well, that too.
Because our predecessors, they had a group of, a group of, Apple, call of activist outside agitators, call, they were Appalachian volunteers who had come here to volunteer in various poverty programs.
And they too lived with local families and encouraged them to apply for benefits and health care.
And hospitals at that time were turning away people didn't have any money.
They just told me we don't do it.
Unwent, I mean pregnant moms couldn't get a delivery.
A lot of terrible stories.
The situation was really pretty grim.
So, and these...
A little while to work your way into the...
Well, I mean, there was a case of when Supreme Court involving the Appalachian volunteers, where I think one of the volunteers was...
Volunteers had threatened a local official or might have even slugged him.
I can't map them.
No, he slugged them.
Well, I don't know. Clark, did he hit them?
I can't say that.
There was a lot of controversy and they...
And that, there was outside agitators and spades.
And they were trying to encourage people to apply for benefits and to get...
And that sort of thing.
And there was...
Health care was very...
It was very poor.
I mean, there were one of our friends started eventually, started a free clinic out here on Mud Creek Clinic.
But there were all those issues that...
If you're trying to promote social justice or environmental justice, but...
And make the system operate a little more fairly, so that poor people have a chance.
And then it isn't just who you are.
And that you have...
So often, at that level, a lawyer makes a big difference.
Many of these people have legal issues.
Family problems.
Disability problems.
I mean, disability benefits.
Consumer law, you can't...
How can you deal with it for closure if you don't have a lawyer?
So your play, I'm sure, in the 43 years has been full all the time.
I mean, especially covering such a wide area.
Absolutely.
Do you have a full play?
You've been there.
So when we were 10 off, we expanded to 10 off...
11 offices.
Okay.
And this was our main administrative office.
And then we started back when I retired in 2002.
We said we were fortunate we started a separate nonprofit to do primarily focus on the coal issues.
Call the Appalachian Citizens Law Center.
But over that time, when we expanded, each of these offices
would cover several counties.
We were hoping we would have four lawyers, at least in every office.
So we could do the day-to-day work and do a major, a larger case.
We sued the state...
Like we sued the state park system.
Because they were discriminating against blacks.
Still, couldn't get a job in the state park system.
If you were black, primarily you'd end up at the bottom.
That was familiar.
But that takes a fair amount of resources.
And locally and a local, a little office.
We did a lot of those fairly major cases.
And day-to-day divorces for people are custody matters that all of them take time.
And no private attorney is going to do them if they're not going to pay you.
So we have...
What I hope to do is have a first-class law firm for poor people away.
John Doerr wanted to put a good bunch of lawyers together for...
to represent the government.
So I think we did some of that.
I think we had a wonderful terrific group of lawyers who were in fairly remote locations in small towns in eastern Kentucky.
So you saw that as something you could do to train that next generation, the next cadre?
I hope there was a good goal.
I think that's what I wanted to do.
And hopefully these folks when you are in the community.
One of the big differences I do think is that I learned to appreciate was that we were in the south
and spent a lot of time preparing cases, but we went home to Washington.
When you're here and folks are in their communities, they also become part of the local community.
So if our kids are in these schools, we care about these schools.
And so Jean saw in a statewide advocacy school.
Whether we've been working on education for many years, not just us, but what you want.
You're trying to create a better community for everybody.
And whether it's schools or the environment.
And the environment is hard because coal miners want...
That's their jobs.
And when people start complaining that regulations are preventing them from mining coal,
it makes it hard to try to demonstrate that you need regulations to protect the environment.
And that that can be done.
You can mine coal responsibly and comply with regulations at the same time.
I mean, you have to...
If you're going to care about these mountains, not a lot of these companies or out-of-state companies.
Don't care about them.
For many years, all the coal underground was owned primarily by out-of-state interest,
and they weren't paying any taxes on that.
So we were able to get that changed.
It's a strange thing about extraction industries.
Oh, yeah.
So oil is a pretty special allowance, for example.
Will that be taken as much as you can?
Then we'll pay you a bonus for all the money you've lost by having taken it out?
Get a little extra.
Well, unfortunately, Kentucky, Alaska and some of the other states had at least set up some trust funds
and put away some money for later on when the severance taxes...
They've never had the...
We have a severance tax here, but most of the lot of that money was spent on roads and economic development
that didn't really pan out.
So this is a very difficult period here.
It's not quite what we're talking about, which is there isn't coal miners are losing their jobs.
And no one has over time been able to demonstrate how to come up with other industries or other replacements.
I mean, we're at a global competition.
We've done things like get our little science museum started.
Right here, we have a nice planetarium.
I saw the science from that.
Oh, yeah.
We saw the science coming in.
It took about 10 years.
We have a very...
I mean, the history of it is really the growing up in Gastonia, NC where we now have a wonderful natural history museum.
That was the father, which was a scout executive I was with.
But so we started talking about trying to do outreach to math and science in math and science in this region in our county
because our scores were so low that students were doing badly.
So badly.
And I was hoping that we could get that...
If we get some brain power going early in math and science, we might be able to affect the future.
Maybe we have some smart kid who will figure out how to do a Silicon Hall or instead of a Silicon Valley.
So we built a very...
We were able...
Because the governor was from the next county and the speaker was from this county.
We politically over a couple of legislatures.
We got enough money together to build this very nice facility with the planetarium.
And a multipurpose classroom and some exhibit space and that sort of thing.
A really nice resource for a community this size.
But there are other things going on here.
There's a re-grossing.
And John was on the advisory board and I was on the advisory board for the local job course center.
And we just want you to know they also had a rocky start here.
But they were very helped by citizens involvement and stuff like that.
Of course, me and I think it's...
I'm just going to ask you if you would sing us down.
Sing us out with a...
We're done.
We're concluding statement.
Sing us down.
What do you think?
Well, we've had a very...
When you reflect on your life,
you feel very fortunate when your values are congruent with what you're doing day to day.
And we've been able to do that.
Can we thank you?
Ta-da.
Cha-ta-cha.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.